[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half an hour we're going to see what's
making the headlines uh with the
journalist and author rachel shabby and
the editor of the jewish chronicle jake
wallis simons so let's have a look at
what is on some of those front pages
well the observer leads with warnings to
british holidaymakers that long delays
at the border between the uk and france
could become the new normal
the sunday telegraph carries an article
by rishi sunak in which he says if he
becomes prime minister
he intends to place an annual cap on the
number of refugees allowed into the
country
and another piece by a politician
appears in the sunday express where
boris johnson insists the government has
got all the big calls right during his
tenure and did get brexit done
the sunday mirror reports that some nhs
staff are being forced to sell their
annual leave days to stay financially
afloat and the sunday people hears from
sources who say that the british army
isn't big enough to participate in the
war in ukraine
the sunday times has seen data
suggesting that only around a fifth of
gps now spend most of their time seeing
patients with others taking on research
posts and leadership roles within the
nhs
and with word that britain is the
hottest it's been since the stone age
the star exclaims
yabba dabba few
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you see on the screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers that's why
while you sit and watch us talk about
them
well we are joined tonight as i was
telling you by rachel shabby and jake
wallace simons really good to see you
both this evening uh what a week it's
been i hope you haven't suffered too
much in the heatwave uh certainly a lot
of people who've been trying to make
their way to get on holiday particularly
heading down to
the port in dover getting uh
pretty
fed up with it aren't they front page of
the observer rachel
travellers being told to expect that
it's going to be the new normal
yeah
they're absolutely right to feel fed up
and frustrated i mean i can imagine you
know
a lot of people are trying to get away
with the school holidays and potentially
you know it's the first time away for a
few years people have been saving up and
looking forward to holidays that are
just being totally
um thwarted or frustrated by these awful
uh cues that we're now being told could
be the new normal this this is a
consequence of brexit it has to be said
um these delays are caused because uh
there now needs to be a passport check
going into france it's worth pointing
out as this piece does
that
this was all anticipated in fact
executives at dover port said to the
government i think it was 2020 they said
look we need a 30 here is a 33 million
pound proposal to double capacity
um at dover port so that we can actually
take on this extra workload that brexit
will create um the government completely
ignored that and lo and behold uh here
we are in this situation for which it
seems there is no end in sight
j what do you think i mean we're told
that grant shacks is on the case that
he's talking to his counterpart
in france but it just seems the tensions
with the french government are just ever
present aren't they
that's right i mean to say that brexit
had nothing to do with this of course
would be wrong uh brexit is in the
picture uh but it's not the whole story
either i mean don't forget brexit we
voted to leave the european union six
years ago that's that's a long time to
get these things sorted
and with the
right will and investment it
should have been achievable quite easily
achievable actually uh but unfortunately
we find ourselves in this situation with
massive tailbacks um you know an
emergency incident declared and and part
of that has got to be the fact that uh
that the french aren't upholding their
part of the deal in trying to make this
new arrangement work uh we know they've
been only only four out of ten passport
booths manned um dover by the french
officials and that doesn't help that
doesn't help um and so i guess it's just
a sense that
the brexit vote has cast a long shadow
and people are still
still feeling bad about it still
harboring resentment and business about
it in the way that's just ruining many
many people's holidays and causing
frustration widespread frustration
across the uk oh rachel because she see
you're shaking your head there and the
relations between the uk and france do
need to improve don't they otherwise
this sort of thing's going to keep
happening
oh of course they do i'm shaking my head
because that directly contradicts what's
actually in this piece um it's worth
looking lord ricketts as a former
ambassador to france he's quoted in this
piece he says
it's the inevitable the delays are
inevitable outcome of the bureaucracy
created by brexit he says the shortage
of uh officials passport officials is
short-term the long-term serious issue
i'm quoting here is that this is the
first time we've seen the full pressure
on the border of brexit this is the
first time we've seen
the
normal summer pressure
on that border because of the pandemic
and it is worth pointing out that the
the french are only doing
what they are legally required to do
according to eu laws which britain
helped to write that is all that france
is doing we have only ourselves to blame
for this situation
well let's hope that things uh certainly
get better down there for people who've
been waiting a very long time in their
cars some of them with
young children
that that gets better as the week goes
on the weekend goes on
let's move on to the
front of the sunday telegraph
jake um
it feels like there's a long way to run
still doesn't it until till we have the
new prime minister in place and we're
going to keep getting new pledges coming
from them uh this is now rishi sunak uh
coming up with a ten point plan uh to
cap the number of refugees
yes i mean this in a way is a reminder
that the next prime minister would be
will be determined by a vote of touring
members
not the the population as a whole
and so both candidates are trying to
make an appeal to the tour membership uh
whose center
he is is further to the right than the
average uh person i suppose um and in
particular uh richard like here is
trying to regain his appeal to the tory
right which liz trust has outflanked him
in um recently and he's trying to do
that by
being tough on on illegal immigration
and if you read the piece that he wrote
there's nothing that he says there
that's particularly either surprising or
controversial he's talking about uh
clamping down on illegal
immigration
uh not immigrant
no
net migration or anything of that sort
jake your line is breaking up a little
bit of of solutions
jake i'm sorry to cut you off but your
line is breaking up a little bit and i
think rachel's keen to come in so what
what did you want to say in response to
that while we try and sort out jake's
line i mean first of all just to agree
with jake that clearly they are pitching
to the party membership which has
dramatically shifted to a quite hard
right position on many things including
tax including immigration this quite
clearly the headline i would cap the
number of refugees says sooner this is
about refugees this is him saying he
wants to
quote inject a healthy dose of common
sense into the asylum system he cannot
do that first of all it's not common
sense it's obtuse uncommon
in compassionate sense secondly
britain is signed up to international
laws on refugees we have a commitment um
if people are seeking asylum in the uk
we are duty-bound to honor that
and you can't just say oh we're not
going to do that suddenly one day unless
you're saying that you're going to tear
up that treaty as well yeah let's come
back to you jake we sort of cut you off
mid-flow there with what with what you
were saying i mean that sometimes the
line
certainly from the perspective of
tory members people who vote for the
tory party that line between refugees
illegal
immigration does tend to get blurred
doesn't it in people's minds
that's right and if you if you read
vicious piece which is inside the
telegraph of which this new story is a
write-off
um as we call it uh you'll see that he
is talking about illegal asylum seekers
not not refugees about illegal
immigrants who come um on dinghies who
come across uh in that way and the
um the ways in which he's talking about
dealing with it range from
uh
putting pressure on employers not to
hire
people without documentation uh illegal
asylum seekers all the way through
to allegedly uh putting them up on on
cruise ships which is quite a strange
eye-catching idea
but either way i think that most people
in the country understand that while we
are a very open country we're
open-hearted we embrace immigration and
we certainly embrace uh uh genuine
refugees to give them a home here it's
the illegal asylum seekers who who come
over to britain particularly across the
channel in dinghys that really is a
problem that is growing month by month
that needs to be addressed for their
sake as well as for us
final word from you on on that
particular article rachel
there there is no such thing as an
illegal asylum seeker that's not a thing
jake's word salad there just indicates
part of the problem it's so jumbled up
and incoherent the conflation of refugee
with migrant there are illegal routes to
the uk and the reason that people are
pursuing those routes is because there
aren't any legal routes if you want to
um prevent people getting into unsafe
dinghies then provide them with safe and
legal routes to seek asylum in the uk
which they are entitled by law to do
all right i think um
i want to
take us onto a slightly lighter note
here and i feel like we can't ignore the
the photograph with the photo heading on
the front of the sunday telegraph the
photograph of boris johnson there in his
in his camouflage lobbing a grenade in
which they've entitled it parting
gesture what do you what do you make of
that rachel
it's kind of like
boris johnson's um
bucket list of things that he wants to
do while
as as prime minister
and
sure whatever it all looks like
bumbling boris johnson doing his jolly
japes thing but he is doing this in the
middle of you know the country
free-falling
in several areas the the cost of living
scandal um
the
the you know problems at the at the
border with people trying to go on
holiday so many things that he should be
looking at and instead he's just
off partying and enjoying himself it is
a bit jarring isn't it yeah so
it depends on what uh
political persuasion you are but uh yes
plenty more for us to talk about and for
you to bicker about
after the break coming up
there are reports tonight that some nhs
staff are being forced to sell their
annual leave days to make ends meet
we're going to be discussing
that coming up for you after
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me again rachel shabby and
jake wallace simons uh good to have you
both uh back um
two pretty big important stories uh on
concerning the nhs pretty dire warnings
as well concerning the nhs uh jake to
you first the sunday times
headline is no longer feasible to be a
full-time gp what does that mean
well i think uh the reverse is probably
true it's no longer feasible to find a
full-time gp i think most people uh in
in britain are finding it very hard to
get appointments with gps particularly
face-to-face and this story makes the
point that most gps are forming
portfolio careers so they are working
part-time as a gp but then also doing
some private work doing some work in
hospitals
and so forth and the time they spend as
a gp also has quite a lot of paperwork
that takes up a lot of their time some
of it of course is is valuable and
important and unavoidable and but
there's part of it that perhaps could be
slimmed down a bit uh but there are some
startling figures in there including the
gps have gone from working something
like 47 hours a week to something like
20 26
so gps are working
much fewer hours as gps
and this of course
is giving the public a far reduced
service and causing people to go to a e
instead of going to their gp surgery out
of despair about getting any kind of
appointment at all so it really is a
difficult
state of affairs that i think everybody
is feeling up and down the country at
the moment when they try to get
appointments with their gp yeah and
meanwhile you've got 6.6 million people
waiting for nhs treatment
yeah okay
um
rachel let's talk that's right i mean
the the waiting
the waiting
sorry go ahead
okay i think we're gonna move on i'm
going to stop my losses with your line
there with your with your line there
jake and come to rachel let's talk about
the front page of the mirror where
you've got staff having to sell their
days off just to make ends meet to pay
their bills
sure so this is uh the mirror reporting
this is an exclusive that um growing
members of nhs staff are basically
selling off their annual
leave as you say in a desperate bid to
just make ends meet um they're giving up
time
and then in return get extra pay now
we're looking at nh service this is
across the nhs at all levels and we're
looking at a workforce that is
burnt out
stressed out overwhelmed
big chunk of them have ptsd actually
after dealing with the horrifying um
stresses and burdens of the pandemic
and
you know we're now hearing the nurses
that some nhs hospitals are frantically
setting up food banks
for nhs staff to access as well so it's
a really dismal state of affairs when
you think about it you know these are
the workers that we're supposed to
cherish and yet we don't treat them like
that the government is not treating them
like that we should not be having a
situation where these staff who we value
so much are forced into using um food
banks well it's also well worth
remembering that in real terms um public
sector pay has not gone up in 10 years
which in real terms means it's taken
it's fallen uh because it hasn't kept up
with the cost of living the very least
we can do
is to make sure nhs staff are paid
at the least in line with inflation